strap yourselves in
we're going to mars not just a few
astronauts
thousands of people are going to
colonize mars
and i am telling you that they're going
to do this soon
some of you will end up working on
projects on mars and i guarantee that
some of your children will end up living
there
that probably sounds preposterous so i'm
going to share with you how and when
that will happen
but first i want to discuss the obvious
question
why the heck should we do this 12 years
ago
i gave a ted talk on 10 ways the world
could end suddenly
we are incredibly vulnerable to the
whims
of our own galaxy a single large
asteroid could take us out forever
to survive we have to reach beyond the
home planet
think what a tragedy it would be if all
that humans have accomplished were
suddenly obliterated
and there's another reason we should go
exploration
is in our dna two million years ago
humans evolved in africa and then slowly
but surely spread out
across the entire planet by reaching
into the wilderness that was beyond
their horizons
this stuff is inside us and they
prospered doing that
some of the greatest advances in
civilization and technology
came because we explored yes we could do
a lot of good with the money it will
take to establish a thriving colony on
mars
and yes we should all be taking far
better care of our own home
planet and yes i worry we could screw up
mars
the way we've screwed up earth
but think for a moment what we had when
john f kennedy
told us we would put a human on the moon
he excited
an entire generation to dream
think how inspired we will be to see a
landing on mars perhaps
then we will look back at earth and see
that that is one people instead of many
and perhaps then we will look back at
earth
as we struggle to survive on mars and
realize how precious the home planet is
so let me tell you about the
extraordinary adventure we're about to
undertake
but first a few fascinating facts about
where we're going
this picture actually represents the
true size of mars compared to earth
mars is not our sister planet it's far
less than half the size of the earth
and yet despite the fact that it's
smaller the surface area of mars that
you can stand on
is equivalent to the surface area of the
earth that you can stand on
because the earth is mostly covered by
water
the atmosphere on mars is really thin a
hundred
times thinner than on earth and it's not
breathable it's 96
carbon dioxide it's really cold there
the average temperature is minus 81
degrees
although there is quite a range of
temperature
a day on mars is about as long as a day
on earth plus about 39 minutes
seasons and years on mars are twice as
long as they are on earth
and for anybody who wants to strap on
some wings and go flying one day
mars has a lot less gravity than on
earth and it's the kind of place where
you could jump over your car instead of
walk around it
now as you can see mars isn't exactly
earth-like
but it's by far the most livable other
place
in our entire solar system here's the
problem
mars is a long way away a thousand times
farther away from us
than our own moon the moon is two
hundred and fifty thousand miles away
and it took apollo astronauts three days
to get there
mars is 250 million miles away
and it will take us eight months to get
there 240 days
and that's only if we launch on a very
specific day at a very specific time
once every two years when mars and the
earth are just
aligned just so so the distance that the
rocket would have to travel will be the
shortest
240 days is a long time to spend trapped
with your
colleagues in a tin can and meanwhile
our track record of getting to mars is
lousy
we and the russians the europeans the
japanese the chinese and the indians
have actually sent
44 rockets there and the vast majority
of them
have either missed or crashed only about
a third
of the missions to mars have been
successful
and we don't at the moment have a rocket
big enough to get there
anyway we once had that rocket the
saturn v
a couple of saturn fives would have
gotten us there it was the most
magnificent machine ever built by humans
and it was the rocket that took us to
the moon but the last saturn 5 was used
in 1973 to launch the skylab space
station and we decided to do something
called the shuttle instead of continuing
on to mars
after we landed on the moon the biggest
rocket we have now is only half big
enough to get us
anything to mars so
getting to mars is not going to be easy
and that brings up
a really interesting question
how soon will the first humans actually
land here
now some pundits think if we got there
by 2050
that'd be a pretty good achievement
these days
nasa seems to be saying that it can get
humans to mars
by 2040. maybe they can't
i believe that they can get human beings
into mars orbit by 2035
but frankly i don't think they're gonna
bother
in 2035 to send a rocket to mars because
we will already be there we're going to
land in mars in 2027.
and the reason is this man is determined
to make that happen
his name is elon musk he's the ceo of
tesla motors
and spacex now he
actually told me that we would land on
mars by 2025
but elon musk is more optimistic than i
am and that's going aways
so i'm giving him a couple of years of
slack
still you got to ask yourself can this
guy
really do this by 2025 or 2027
well let's put a decade with elon musk
into a little perspective
where was this 10 years ago that's the
tesla electric automobile
in 2005 a lot of people in the
automobile industry were saying we would
not have a decent electric car for 50
years
and where was that that is spacex's
falcon 9 rocket
lifting 6 tons of supplies to the
international space station
10 years ago spacex had not launched
anything
or fired a rocket to anywhere
so i think it's a pretty good bet that
the person who is revolutionizing the
automobile industry in less than 10
years and the person
who created an entire rocket company in
less than 10 years
will get us to mars by 2027.
now you need to know this governments
and robots no longer control this game
private companies are leaping into space
and they will be happy to take you to
mars
and that raises a really big question
can we actually live there
now nasa may not be able to get us there
until 2040 or we may get there a long
time before nasa but nasa has taken a
huge responsibility in figuring out how
we can live on mars
let's look at the problem this way
here's what you need to live on earth
food water shelter and clothing
and here's what you need to live on mars
all of the above
plus oxygen so let's look at the most
important
thing on this list first water is the
basis of all life as we know it
and it's far too heavy for us to carry
water from the earth to mars to live
so we have to find water if our life is
going to succeed
on mars and if you look at mars it looks
really dry it looks like an
the entire planet is a desert but it
turns out that it's not
the soil alone on mars contains up to 60
percent water
and a number of orbiters that we still
have flying around mars
have shown us and by the way that's a
real photograph
that lots of craters on mars have a
sheet of water ice in them
it's not a bad place to start a colony
now here's a view of a little dig the
phoenix lander did in 2008
showing that just below the surface of
the soil is ice that white stuff
is ice in the second picture which is
four days later in the first picture you
can see that some of it is evaporating
orbiters also tell us that there are
huge amounts of underground water on
mars
as well as glaciers in fact if
only the water ice at the poles on mars
melted
most of the planet would be under 30
feet of water
so there's plenty of water there but
most of it's ice most of it's
underground it takes a lot of energy to
get it and a lot of human labor
this is a device cooked up at the
university of washington back in 1998
it's basically a low-tech dehumidifier
and it turns out the mars atmosphere is
often 100
humid so this device can extract
all the water that humans will need
simply from the atmosphere on mars
next we have to worry about what we will
breathe frankly i was really shocked
to find out that nasa has this problem
worked out
this is a scientist in mit named michael
hecht
and he's developed this machine moxie i
love this thing
it's a reverse fuel cell essentially
that sucks in the martian atmosphere
and pumps out oxygen and you have to
remember that co2 carbon dioxide which
is 96
of mars atmosphere co2 is basically 78
oxygen now the next big rover the nasa
sends to mars
in 2020 is going to have one of these
devices aboard
and it will be able to produce enough
oxygen to keep one person alive
indefinitely but the secret to this
and that's just for testing the secret
to this is that this thing was designed
from the get-go to be scalable
by a factor of a hundred next
what will we eat well we'll use
hydroponics
to grow food but we're not going to be
able to grow more than 15 to 20 percent
of our food there at least not until
water is running on the surface of mars
and we actually have the probability
and the capability of planting crops
in the meantime most of our food will
arrive from earth
and it will be dried and then
we need some shelter at first
we can use inflatable pressurized
buildings as well as the landers
themselves
but this really only works during the
daytime there is
too much solar radiation and too much
radiation from cosmic rays
so we really have to go underground now
it turns out that the soil on mars by
and large
is perfect for making bricks and nasa
has figured this one out too
they're going to throw some polymer
plastic into the bricks
shove them in a microwave oven and then
you will be able to build buildings with
really thick walls
or we may choose to live underground in
caves
or in lava tubes of which there are
plenty
and finally there's clothing on earth we
have
miles of atmosphere piled up on us which
creates 15 pounds of pressure on our
bodies at all times
and we're constantly pushing out against
that on mars there's hardly any
atmospheric pressure
so davin newman a scientist at mit
has created this sleek spacesuit it will
keep us together
block radiation and keep us warm
so let's think about this for a minute
food shelter clothing
water oxygen we can do this
we really can but it's still a little
complicated
and a little difficult so that leads
to the next big really big step
in living the good life on mars and
that's terraforming the planet
making it more like earth re-engineering
an entire planet that sounds like a lot
of hubris
but the truth is that the technology to
do everything i'm about to tell you
already exists
first we've got to warm it up mars is
incredibly cold
because it has a very thin atmosphere
the answer lies here
at the south pole and at the north pole
of mars both of which
are covered with an incredible amount of
frozen carbon dioxide
dry ice if we heat it up it sublimes
directly
into the atmosphere and thickens the
atmosphere the same way it does on earth
and as we know co2 is an incredibly
potent
greenhouse gas now my favorite way of
doing this
is to erect a very very large solar sail
and focus it essentially serves as a
mirror and focus it on the south pole of
mars
at first as the planet spins it will
heat up
all that dry ice sublime it and it will
go into the atmosphere
it actually won't take long for the
temperature on mars to start rising
probably less than 20 years
right now on a perfect day at the
equator
in the middle of summer on mars
temperatures can actually reach 70
degrees
but then they go down to minus 100 at
night
what we're shooting for is a runaway
greenhouse effect
enough temperature rise to see a lot of
that ice on mars
especially the ice in the ground melt
then we get some real magic as the
atmosphere gets thicker everything
gets better we get more protection from
radiation
more atmosphere makes us warmer makes
the planet warmer so we get running
water
and that makes crops possible then more
water vapor goes into the air forming
yet another potent greenhouse gas
it will rain and it will snow on mars
and a thicker atmosphere will create
enough pressure
so that we can throw away those
spacesuits we only need about five
pounds of pressure to survive
eventually mars will be made to feel
a lot like british columbia we'll still
be left with the complicated problem of
making the atmosphere breathable and
frankly that could take
a thousand years to accomplish but
humans are amazingly smart and
incredibly adaptable
there is no telling what our future
technology will be able to
accomplish and know telling what we can
do with our own bodies
we in biology right now we are on
the very verge of being able to control
our own genetics
what the genes in our own bodies are
doing and
certainly eventually our own evolution
we could end up with a species of human
being on the earth
that is slightly different from the
species of human beings on mars
but what would you do there how would
you live it's going to be the same as it
is on earth
somebody's going to start a restaurant
somebody's going to build an
iron foundry someone will make
documentary movies of mars and sell them
on earth
some idiot will start a reality tv show
there will be software companies there
will be hotels there will be bars
this much is certain it will be the most
disruptive
event in our lifetimes and i think it
will be the most inspiring
ask any 10 year old girl if she wants to
go to mars
children who are now in elementary
school are going to choose
to live there remember when we landed
humans on the moon
when that happened people looked at each
other and said if we can do this we can
do anything
what are they going to think when we
actually form a colony
on mars most importantly
it will make us a space faring species
and that means humans will survive no
matter
what happens on earth we will never be
the last of our kind thank you